nach Stunden über Schotterpisten nähern
wir uns dem Epizentrum das Berberdorf im
Atlasgebirge liegt nur wenige Kilometer
entfernt Asis ist in der Region
aufgewachsen bis vergangene Woche noch
hat er Touristen hierhergeführt haben
sie mit den Bewohnern bei Tee
zusammengesessen von den 120 Häusern
steht so gut wie keines mehr
Uni trist wir sind traurig wir waren dem
Erdbeben völlig ausgeliefert Gott
entscheidet über uns
das geht uns allen sehr nahe
immer wieder kehren sie in die Ruinen
ihrer Häuser zurück schauen nach Hab und
Gut schauen was noch zu retten ist die
die überlebt haben campieren Unterdecken
und in Not Zelten Asis führt mich zu
einem Lager zu Fatima die er schon lange
kennt sie ist in dem Dorf aufgewachsen
in einer großen Familie sieben von ihnen
sind gestorben mit ihren eigenen Händen
hat Fatima nach ihnen gegraben
wir haben selbst versucht sie zu
befreien sie haben geschrieben bis sie
verstummt bis sie gestorben sind die
Steine das alles viel so plötzlich auf
uns einige konnten wir retten aber wir
sind nicht an alle herangekommen
loslasst
auch die katastrophenschütze aus
Großbritannien kommen an Tag 4 nach dem
Erdbeben zu spät mit ihren Hunden haben
sie in den eingestürzten Häusern nach
Lebenszeichen gesucht vergeblich
wir hatten Informationen dass es in
diesem Dorf noch Verschüttete zu retten
gibt aber dann wurde klar es gibt viele
Tote aber keine Menschen denen wir noch
helfen können
und deshalb fahren wir jetzt wieder
zurück in unser Basecamp
das haben sie am Fuße des hohen Atlas
aufgeschlagen koordinieren ihre Einsätze
zusammen mit spanischen Rettungskräften
und den Kataris die gerade eingetroffen
sind sie gehören zu den Ländern deren
Hilfsangebote von der marokkanischen
Regierung angenommen wurden von hier aus
steuern Sie nach und nach die Bergdörfer
an
einem maximalen Grad der Zerstörung es
gibt keine Hohlräume in den Gebäuden in
denen wir gehofft hatten Überlebende zu
finden das was eingestürzt ist ist
komplett eingestürzt
mit einer Stärke von 6,8 bebt in der
Nacht zu Samstag die Erde so stark wie
seit 100 Jahren nicht niemand ist
vorbereitet die einfach gebauten Häuser
halten dem Erdbeben nicht stand
internationale Unterstützung wird
schnell angeboten doch nur zögerlich
werden die Helfer ins Land gelassen
2900 tote fünfeinhalb tausend verletzte
das sind die bisherigen zahlen doch das
ganze Ausmaß der Katastrophe ist noch
immer nicht erfasst
wir sammeln Informationen darüber was
gebraucht wird das können schutzzelte
sein Essen Wasser Medizin und diese
Infos geben wir dann an die
Hilfsorganisationen weiter die nach uns
hierher kommen werden
das Erdbeben hat die Ärmsten Gebiete
getroffen weniger die urbanen Zentren
von dort geht nun eine berührende Welle
der Solidarität aus isham hat nicht
lange überlegt und gleich am nächsten
Morgen in seiner Nachbarschaft in
Casablanca Spenden gesammelt
Milch was für die Kinder
und wir haben auch Babyflaschen
vor ihnen liegt eine ganze Tagestour
isham macht sie nicht zum ersten Mal er
war schon einmal oben in den Bergen traf
auf Hinterbliebene die verzweifelt waren
und auf sich allein gestellt
an dem Tag war ich in einem Dorf in der
Region armsmiss wir waren mit 20 Autos
da alle voll beladen sie hatten dort
nichts zu essen als Sie uns entdeckt
haben haben sie gestrahlt
aus allen Teilen Marokkos machen sich
freiwillige auf den Weg Autos
Transporter schlängeln sich vollgepackt
über die Passstraßen die gerade erst
freigeräumt wurden
am Ortseingang von du so stapeln sich
die Spenden sie werden nach und nach an
die Familien verteilt die versuchen sich
zwischen den Trümmern irgendwie
einzurichten andere blicken wie gelähmt
auf die Zerstörung und werden die Bilder
der Erdbeben Nacht nicht los
was ich nie vergessen kann wir haben
eine Frau gefunden die ihr Kind in den
Armen hielt sie hat versucht ihr Kind zu
retten aber sie sind beide gestorben
verstehst Du was ich sage sie nahm ihr
Kind versuchte aufzustehen und dann
starben sie gemeinsam
er sieht keine Zukunft weder für sich
noch für das Dorf
glaubst du dass wir hier weiterleben
können dass es hier wieder einen Alltag
geben wird
für die Kinder versucht Fatima stark zu
bleiben sie weiß es wird nicht leicht
wenn nun Herbst und Winter kommen und
bei aller Dankbarkeit über die Hilfe in
der Not hofft sie dass diese nicht nur
von kurzer Dauer ist dass die
Aufmerksamkeit nicht so schnell wieder
schwindet
all die Kinder und Familien brauchen ein
Zuhause und uns ist kalt all das hier
wird von großzügigen hilfsbereiten
Menschen zur Verfügung gestellt aber wir
haben keinen Platz zum Bleiben wo wir
leben können
hunderttausende sind von dem Unglück
betroffen und die Rettungskräfte waren
noch immer nicht überall in der Region
Asis sieht am Abend weiter ins nächste
Dorf um dort zu fragen woran es fehlt
doch vorher wollen sie die Hilfsgüter
vor dem Regen schützen den sie in der
Nacht befürchten